we are back with the incredible emily
ratakowski
this book
when you are having you know women
young women read it any female out there
i think it obviously pertains to men but
i'm just curious about the women um
what do you
if you could um
say that
you would like them to get from the book
i mean i think that you know there's
just so much
conflict and nuance and things that are
shrouded like power dynamics in our in
the reality of what it means to be a
woman you know i think it doesn't you
don't have to be in the industry to
relate to you know getting dressed in
the morning and knowing like oh this
shirt is a little tight um i'm going to
get some attention that i'll probably
like and also some attention that might
not be so great and that's every woman
yes don't we all get dressed trying to
figure out what messages are we sending
today yeah so i think that you know i
wanted to i feel like when i'm in my
close intimate female friendships and
we're talking about this stuff it's like
an understanding we're being vulnerable
we're kind of talking about the ways
that can make us feel good and feel bad
and i wanted to to be able to shine a
light on those complexities um and you
know kind of just
pull the the veil off of those power
dynamics and say like let's let's let
this be accepted as more
as an understanding of our world and you
are anything but a victim you are in the
driver's seat absolutely and
i love
the road you are taking no i am not a
victim at all and i think that's really
was important for me to to have that in
the book oh no you are no chump you are
one seriously intelligent and strong
self-aware thank you you're very
self-aware
all right well when we announced that
you were coming on the show today we
heard from a bunch of women okay um who
were really inspired by you telling your
story and um some of them had a message
for you i'd love to show you please okay
take a look hello emily my name is kenna
vasquez and i wanted to make this to
thank you for being an inspiration to
women everywhere including myself and i
wanted to also say thank you for
speaking about women's issues that most
women feel silenced about i really
appreciate that you take the time to
actually do that emily my name is
michelle elizabeth as a woman i always
felt that my power was given away to men
where i felt like i was an object to
them and they were in charge you telling
your story has made me feel that i am
charging my body and i thank you for
that hey emily i'm amanda baez thank you
for using your big platform to just
share the importance of consent and that
this is my body
this is my temple the fact that you're
going through the same circumstances
that i'm going through it just shows
that we're all going through the same
things and that just didn't make me feel
alone so thank you for sharing your
story just thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
it's really good i mean you're 30
30
yeah
i'm 46 and i feel like i've gone on a
lifelong journey with you in this book
oh and you've healed me from things that
my younger years engaging in
relationships was something that
i don't talk about a lot i have kids and
i won't talk about it now that window is
closed yeah um but it doesn't mean that
i don't still deal with things inside
and look at my daughters and think
how things
can be different for them you know that
they can have somebody to talk to who's
looking out for them and caring about
every step of their journey
i can't control them i can't fix it for
them but i can be there
to impart
a shepherding wisdom and net and love
and lifelong experiences that i would
not know
unless i lived them myself
and um
i i just i thank you oh thank you so
much thank you so much
um
all right your new book it's pub day um
my body i love that you didn't put your
face on there i've heard that being
talked about
it's gonna be available now and um
congratulations
[Applause]
tyler
[Music]